hersin
[Applaudissements]
votre invité sonia mabrouk et
commissaire au plan maire de pau et
président du modem dans le désordre
bienvenue seront rampant et bonjour
françois bayrou bonjour est ce qu il a
déjà gagné
de qui parle-t-on de poutine il sait que
personne n'ira mourir pour kiev
en tout état de cause en tout cas bien
sûr il ya un rapport de force qui si
menaçant
si violent
que l'on voit que des décisions les
décisions les plus lourdes sont à
prendre
et les décisions les plus lourdes pour
dissuader si on peut encore le faire
pour dissuader d'une accélération ce
dont on ne se rend pas compte c'est que
dans ce genre de situation on est devant
un engrenage et cet engrenage il peut
conduire au pire vous avez entendu comme
moi différentes reprises poutine menacé
de vitrifier parle armes nucléaires ceux
qui s'opposeraient à lui qui croit
l'arme nucléaire c'est évidemment la
dissuasion qui ne croit que le il y a
des moments
où les dirigeants notamment quand ce
sont des dictateurs
sont menacés de dérive où son peuvent
être sujets à des dérives qu'on ne
contrôle pas je ne sais pas si vous avez
vu on a vu cette nuit hier soir sur les
réseaux sociaux en face à face
hallucinant entre poutine et son chef de
la sécurité son chef des services de
sécurité
deux du renseignement russe
et c'était une humiliation en direct
parce qu'on voyait bien que le chef du
renseignement russes n'étaient pas sur
la même ligne il était non pas le cash
menace collective qu'est ce qui se passe
monsieur bayrou il avait annoncé qu'il
est annexerait quelques années la crimée
ces faits il avait dit pour
l'indépendance d'une bombe à ces faits
que vont faire les occidentaux ils
prendront aucun risque pour l'ukraine à
votre interrogation est de l'ordre du
tout ou rien
toujours à la tête et quand vous êtes à
la tête d'un état ou d'un ensemble
d'états que vous leur présentez vous ne
pouvez pas être dans le tour ou rien
vous pouvez pas être dans la guerre ou
bien on s'écrase
il y à toute une gamme
d'engagement par exemple des engagements
de sanctions financières très durs à
l'égard des oligarques lit du système
pour l'instant sciemment ses parts dans
les mains j'ai sur semois sais pas ce
qui est prévu par le présent maritime
byden il ne parle pas de ces sanctions
là pour les eaux les gars qui parle de
sanctions plus générales qui reviendra
en boomerang sur qui si vous permettez
monsieur byden c'est une chose et nous
européens c'en est une autre il faut que
nous prenions l'habitude d'avoir notre
propre ligne indépendante mais sommes
pas d'accord mais chez bayrou
l'allemagne ne fera rien compte tenu de
l'importance du gamin qui ne fera rien
de quoi lorsque des décisions qui
étaient des décisions avant tu ré ou
aventureuse ont fait en sorte que
l'allemagne devienne dépendante du gaz
russe et cet énorme pression qui a été
créé en allemagne avec la complicité
d'un certain nombre de dirigeants et qui
a créé aussi sur la france avec la
complicité active
d'un certain nombre de dirigeants
politiques de responsables politiques
sur les deux bords de l'échiquier qui
vivait ben y en a qui sont absolument
claire en a failli avoir un président de
la république ou en tout cas certains
voulaient connaître président de la
république françois fillon qui dont tout
le monde sait désormais qu'il est
directement mais de là à influencer la
ligne politique russe il ya quand même
une main non mais vous voyez bien ce
n'est pas ce que je dis ce que je dis
c'est que depuis des années il y à une
pression de poutine et à cette pression
de poutine qui résiste en réalité il
n'ya que le président de la république
française qui est apporté une résistance
à une résistance de portes ouvertes il a
fait de son mieux il a fait une action
diplomatique mais reconnaissait que
force à face à l'ours russe indomptables
c'est un camouflet diplomatique pour
nous tous je joue ce jeune réseau rente
est un genre de ce genre de maxime
l'occe russe indomptables
pour l'instant il s'agit de menaces sur
notre sécurité est jeune et je ne
mélange pas je ne donne pas des
adjectifs
valorisant à des menaces sur notre
sécurité et voulait devenir président
français dit manque elle est le fruit de
son action diplomatique sur la lancée de
son action c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya au
moins quelqu'un parmi les dirigeants qui
résistent qui résistent sans céder un
parent et en laissant toujours une porte
ouverte à la pelle j'ai trouvé ça
l'attitude la plus la plus juste et en
effet il ya en europe des dirigeants qui
ont été allez je vais l'employé le moule
plus gentille et influencé par la russie
influencé par poutine il y en a qui sont
candidats à la présidence de la
république nombreux sur les deux bords
qui ont qui ont vanté la fiabilité de
poutine la rationalité de poutine a
expliqué mme hamm se verront peut être
équidistant entre les etats-unis et la
russie sans être pro russe quand même
est-ce que vous voyez des nuances dans
les positions je ne sais pas si ceux-ci
vous avez appelé ça de l'équidistance
tous ceux qui sont allés se faire
adouber par poutine avait dit clairement
au parler de marine le pen pas seulement
mais dit il en a visés quelqu'un avec
avec des attitudes qui sont des
attitudes deux allées d'une telle
reconnaissance que ça conduit à la
soumission moi en tout cas je suis
heureux que il y ait des forces et
notamment au centre de la vie politique
française une force dont vous savez bien
que dans l'histoire jamais elle n'a cédé
1 mm à ce type de dicter oui pour quel
résultat aujourd'hui est bien le
résultat sera celui que nous formons nos
logiciels est d'ailleurs moi je vous dis
je suis persuadé qu'il y à des sanctions
vous parliez du gaz très bien je suis
persuadé qu'il y ait des sanctions des
modes de résistance des manières de de
manifester quelque chose d'irréductible
dans la position qui est la nôtre tout
en ne se laissant pas entraîner dans
l'engrenage de la guerre bien si vous ne
direz vous agi parce que les sanctions
n'ont pas eu d'effet jusque là et sans
revenu en boomerang sont les repères
vous ne m'avez pas écouté jeu alors je
répète
c'est un régime qui est sensible aux
sanctions financières de ceux qui sont
ses affidés qui sont extrêmement engagés
dans un certain nombre de choses c'est
un régime qui est sensible à toutes les
questions de matières premières vous
savez que la russie est un pays dont le
pib est extrêmement réduit c'est le pib
dit on de l'espagne pour un pays qui est
30 fois plus grand que la france et qui
à peine deux fois plus peuplé que la
france est une une armée d'une ou d'un
tel poids d'une telle puissance
fondée sur un produit intérieur brut et
une économie aussi faible ce sont des
zones de fragilité et donc je ne crois
pas que nous soyons sans défense sans
armes sans capacité de parler à
condition que nous acceptions d'être
nous mêmes c'est à dire indépendant des
deux puissances qu'ils s'affrontent ou
bien je vous ramène à la situation
politique française de ce maillot est ce
qu'on est au bord d'une crise de régime
qui se joue sous nos yeux si l'un des
trois candidats jean luc mélenchon
marine le pen eric zemmour deux ou trois
n'obtenez pas leur parrainage vous avez
dit on risque un tsunami démocratique
qu'est ce que ça veut dire le voit le
jeune ami vous observez comme moi la
situation de la société française qu'est
ce qui est marquant c'est une extrême
défiance
des citoyens à l'égard des institutions
d extrême défiance
les français ne croient plus à
l'autorité ne croit plus à l'autorité
politique qui a longtemps ne croit plus
à l'autorité religieuse dit encore plus
longtemps ne croit plus à l'autorité
médiatique ne vous trompez pas vous êtes
ne me trompe pas est dans l'oeil du
cyclone et non mais je ne crois
grande confiance ne croit plus à
l'autorité
scientifique ne croit plus à l'autorité
médicale ils ont vu sur vos plateaux les
médecins se déchiraient entre eux et ça
leur a laissé un goût amer elle
conseille en plus soyez donc quand il ya
une situation de défiance comme celle là
la question est
que notre démocratie doit au moins leur
garantir l'honnêteté des consultations
sinon quoi je veux comprendre si il y
avait corner très bien je crois mais je
préfère qu'on me formalise les choses
parce que si on en arrive à là c'est
quand même important pour notre jeu
qu'on veut pas dire on arrivait ou selon
dire un mot pourquoi parce que vous avez
cette initiative il faut le dire qui est
saluée par tous cette banque des
parrainages je rappelle que le site qui
est mis en place s'intitule notre
démocratie point fr il comptait hier
près de 85 maires c'est bien cela étant
aujourd'hui nous dépassons 120 cette
importance en mer capables de donner
leurs parrainages ces trois candidats
vous en espérez beaucoup plus là dans
les prochaines 12 heures laura plus
parce que ces mères disent une chose
très simple c'est mr c est lui capable
de parrainer 10
nous voulons garantir que la démocratie
soit transparente que puisse se
présenter même des gens avec qui nous
sommes en désaccord profond parce que la
démocratie c'est ça c'est souhaité qu'il
y ait
compétition des opinions et
affrontements claire des opinions et
nous voulons le faire mais nous ne
voulons pas être considérés comme des
soutiens de ceux qui de ceux pour qui
nous allons signer c'est pourquoi nous
allons ensemble collectivement
prendre cette initiative de garantir que
tous ceux qui sont inscrits là ils
soutiennent parce que ils veulent une
garantie démocratique mais ils ne
veulent pas être engagées contre leur
gré on a compris un parrainage ne vaut
pas ce chat mais est ce que vous dites
que cette centaine de maires on l'espère
plus pourra garantir que ces trois
candidats jean luc mélenchon marine le
pen aurait eu des mots soient vraiment
présents puissent concourir achevé
l'ancien chabot on peut pas encore dire
jours de fermeture du résultat de
l'opération naturellement ils n'ont pas
les signatures il reste sept jours
ouvrables c'est très bien
le temps cette enseigne jours
on a on a devant nous quelques jours
pour que l'on puisse faire le bilan
précis acquis manque-t-il des signatures
selon moi il en manque aux 3 est pas mal
en tout cas c'est ce que me disent mes
contacts eh bien on fera en sorte
démocratiquement collectivement
civiquement c'est le vrai mot en france
surtout civiquement de garantir qu'il
puisse se présenter france à bayeux vous
avez interrogé il ya quelques mois et
vous avez été l'un des premiers faut le
reconnaître a tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
sur ce sujet quand certains avaient dit
que ces candidats se victimiser qu'il
exagérait on comprend aujourd'hui que ce
n'est pas le cas malgré tout je voudrais
vous faire écouter un candidat qui était
hier à votre plat sera bien russell lui
affirme qu'il ne veut pas encourager les
mères notamment communiste a donné leur
parrainage des candidats dit-il
d'extrême droite comme marine le pen ou
riz moore et que s'ils n'ont pas obtenu
ces parrainages c'est de leur faute
écoutons le si certains n'arrivent pas
les avoir c'est qu'ils ont un problème
avec
la république avec les élus pour ne pas
réussir à les convaincre je ferai tout
pour que en tout cas de chez moi il n'y
a aucune signature en direction de
l'extrême droite 9 à vous rendez compte
le danger qu'il représente
voyez c'est exactement ce que ce que
nous diagnostiquons ensemble c'est
confondre je signe pour qu'il puisse se
présenter même si je suis en désaccord
profond avec eux ou bien je signe parce
que je soutiens alors fabien roussel
c'est assez simple sans vouloir dire des
choses sans vouloir trahir des secrets
la dernière fois les élus communistes
signait pour jean luc mélenchon alors
cette fois ci ils ont retiré ce soutien
et c'est peut-être une des explications
que l'on que l'on voit là moi en tout
cas
je ne confonds pas
l'attitude civique de ceux qui veulent
garantir qu'une démocratie soit juste
honnête et transparente qu'à l'intérieur
en sont en désaccord profond mais qu'au
moins les citoyens et la certitude que
le vote est
juste qu'ils pourront exprimer leurs
opinions
vous savez à ceux qui disent monsieur
bayrou oui mais il faudrait peut-être
faire barrage à des candidats qui ne
porterait pas des valeurs démocratiques
vous dit que c'est aux français j'ai
choisi cette aux français de choisir et
des candidats qui ne porte pas des
valeurs démocratiques comme vous dites
et y en a certains sur tous les bords
je suis en assez grand désaccord avec la
plupart de ceux dont vous avez cité le
nom et même en opposition
absolument franche avec ce dont vous
avez cité le nom est cependant je dis
que nous avons le devoir et la charge de
garantir que cette démocratie pourra
être par les français considéraient
comme leur instrument vous savez la
démocratie c'est le seul moyen qu'on ait
trouvé pour que les fractures se
réduisent un peu pour que les
affrontements se changent simplement en
controverses qu'on n'est pas la guerre
civile dans le pays il faut y ajouter un
peu de compréhension réciproque question
peut un peu d'humour parce que ça aide
beaucoup flamarens situation même pas
avec de l'humour mais vous êtes pour
l'appui à wray pluralité des mots que je
suis pour le pluralisme plus rallier des
cv de suite pour la proportionnelle je
le suis pour la banque de la débrouille
et ainsi que j'ai pu me poser votre
budget il
ya aucun doute pourquoi d'ailleurs pour
convaincu ben pourquoi vous êtes
convaincus de voter de nouveau pour
emmanuel macron pas parce que j'ai
observé pendant ces cinq années quelles
sont les orientations profondes où sa
boussole va et sa boussole va ce que je
croyais plus juste une société qui se
reconstruit une france qui se réarment
dans une europe qui est dans le monde
1 une intervention en direction de la
concorde et de la paix si on a ça si on
n'oublie pas qu'on a beaucoup par
reconstruire chez nous école
rue reconquête de la production
organisation de l'état
est aussi démocratie alors je suis sûr
que ce quinquennat sur un quinquennat
utile et quand je vois l'état du monde
et que je vois le rôle qu'ils jouent le
président de la république française je
me dis mais qui pourrait parmi ceux qui
se présentent jouer le même rôle en tous
les cas les autres ambitionne également
et c'est aux français de choisir vous
l'avez très bien dit monsieur b on va
attendre que le président se déclare
également officiellement candidat merci
merci à vous d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin bonne journée à fond